angelina jolie and the weeknd are
sparking dating rumors again after being
spotted together saturday night and e.t
has new details about their intimate
dinner and it was very exciting the 46
year old actress and the 31 year old
singer ate at giorgio baldi in los
angeles the same restaurant they dined
at in june although they arrived
separately within five minutes apart
from each other an eyewitness tells e.t
they left together in the singer's car
and headed towards his bel-air home
[Music]
the pair matched in all black the
actress wore a trench coat and pumps
while the singer coordinated in skinny
jeans and a jacket angelina and the
weeknd sat in a private area of the
restaurant and were not joined by anyone
else and get this our source says they
had dinner for two and a half hours it
was such a pleasure while we don't know
what went down during all that time the
source confirmed that they seemed pretty
relaxed like they had a good night we
were a little more comfortable and the
source described the weekend as pretty
serious as he usually is
these hangouts come amid angelina's
ongoing legal woes with ex brat pitt she
finalized her divorce from the actor in
2019
but the former couple is still in a
custody battle over their six children
it's just so wonderful to have their
their you know they're my friends as for
the weekend he previously dated selena
gomez in 2017
and had an on and off relationship with
bella hadid from 2015 to 2019. i love
you guys while angelina and the weeknd
haven't confirmed a romantic
relationship our source adds the two
seem like they didn't mind being spotted
out together this time around
you